allora ragazzi io non so se state
capendo l'importanza di questi due
cuscini ok non lo so però ve la butto lì
da circa 3 4 giorni a questa parte sono
la mia vita della serie che preferisco
dormire con questa roba che con una
bella [ __ ] a me non piace harry potter e
mi fa boschivo ed affitti ragazzi e fair
minuti a questo nuovo video sono fari
jlg siamo in un nuovo logo allora un
sacco di roba da dirvi quindi cominciamo
subito perché non c'è ragazzi come al
solito partiamo con la panarda settimana
che questa settimana è stata vinta da
ginevra e c'è una particolarità i
capelli sono troppo ordinati c'è non
sono così belli in teoria ci sono degli
evidenti problemi e direi che possiamo
partire col blog di two day passando le
news la prima di oggi è velocissima poi
sapete tutti che quando io registro i
miei video sono molto calmo con gli
oggetti che intorno cani quella vacca
lytham ed è per questo motivo che
inspiegabilmente l'altro giorno vi sia
scassato e filmica che poi guardate il
bellissimo dietro al microfono minimo
perché c'è dietro e davanti dietro è
fatto così tutto bello tutto normale e
davanti e tutto mischiato perché quando
sbatto le cose in genere mica del
microfono e vabbè il risultato si vede
ho preso quindi un microfono nuovo tutto
professional che non faccio vedere la
marca che seno sembra che faccio il
prodotto piazzamenti che di una figata
che ci ho paura di rovinarlo che mi
chiamo rose volta tiro i calci al muro
piuttosto che non toccarlo parlando
sempre di migliorie tecniche del canale
molti di voi mi stanno chiedendo cosa
cazzo è quella roba lì che è comparsa
nei miei video ultimamente in realtà
esistono le cose che si chiamano
riflettori che praticamente riflettono
la luce serve per rendere migliore la
luce dei video il problema è che quando
ho comprato quella roba lì non ho preso
bene le misure voi non vi state
realmente accorgendo di quanto cazzo e
grosso quell'affare attualmente la
situazione è questa e quindi siccome
casa mia non è così tanto grande e non
so dove cazzo metterlo è l'unico posto
disponibile visto che è sottile e
incastrarlo tra l'armadio e il muro
motivo e magari si chiedono ma fallì ma
che cazzo te fai a fare queste migliorie
tecniche tanto chissenefrega della
lucina in più che su youtube puoi fare
vide in mutande
se manco se ne accorge tipo io adesso va
bene ragazzuoli c'è la news della vita
della vita siete pronti questo weekend
quindi già oggi io sarò al tomorrowland
2016 mi pare che tipo da 2011 che sto
tenendo d'occhio tomorrowland che mi
piace tantissimo ho una felicità addosso
che non vi posso descrivervi dico già
che blogger o tutto quatu qual sia anche
il cesso di blogo anche al cesso e
proprio anche bello l'ambiente magari vi
fa cagare quel tipo di musica ma è bello
proprio l'ambiente in generale quindi
magari mail vado lì e poi mettono gianni
morandi tutto il giorno che cazzo ne so
però a parte sta cagata qua volevo dirvi
che da una vita e mezza mi state cagando
non posso far vedere perché sono
abbondantemente nudo premi state
travasando il cazzo sulla roba della
tavola ouija ok l'altro giorno invitato
a casa mia miei amici e abbiamo deciso
di fare sta minkia tali tavola ouija
molti di voi compresi i miei genitori e
non pensavo mi dicono non si fanno
queste cose sono pochi l'ec le cose
quando evochi queste cose ti esce fuori
in pokémon che cazzo ne so veramente
curioso quanta gente mi ha detto davvero
di non fare questa cosa c'è me l'hanno
scritto alcuni mi hanno scritto pomo
seriamente della serie non fare questa
cosa come se è veramente io potessi
evocare uno spirito c'è gente che
veramente ci crede cioè allora io sono
io sono una persona molto scettica di
mio ed è ovvio che non è successo niente
perché l'ho già fatto e non è successo
niente
o almeno è quello che pensavo prima di
farla perché in realtà qualcosa di
strano è veramente successo io l'ho
fatto comunque sia anche se è una cosa
che non si dovrebbe fare perché comunque
la tavola ouija è un [ __ ] gioco della
hasbro adesso arriviamo a esagerazioni
che mou è poco veramente i demoni del
state tranquilli che siamo su youtube di
demoni ci sono solo i miei capelli
tranne una cosa abbastanza particolare
che non mi sono spiegato che è successa
durante il video buona visione
type 1 chiama per documentare questa
cosa che stiamo per fare una sembrati pò
troppo film horror che sto facendo
ma rischia mare il caffè
comunque sia sono le 310 di notte anzi
un po tardi perché questo qua indietro
fate vivere fantasma lo sta facendo
perché l'ho visto fare negli horror con
dove c'è il protagonista di turno che fa
finta di fare il [ __ ] del tipo
capelli ed ex pec e poi puntualmente
qualcuno glielo infila nel culo pesante
[ __ ] stromae sverginata la l'alba a
prof
beh senza uno spirito che mi sale questa
quadra tavola proprio in sé per sé è
dopodiché abbiamo questo che è il corso
che dobbiamo tenere il summit altro
collega come ci sono solo questi due
cortile dove si forza danno veramente 30
euro in italia gitana tava è un collo
famiglia con 5 mila lire mia falegname
la famiglia ci metterei le camere
dobbiamo toccare tutti sta roba ma con
quante mani con due dita 21 11 dic a un
dito spiriti potenti vivono chiamo lo so
svegliamo spirito timbo con spirito
potente che sono bene la potente sei tu
che cari e magrolino
spirito che sei in questa stanza
dacci un segno ma [ __ ] giorgio
almeno non buttare del telefono porca
[ __ ] spirito che se in questa stanza
se ci sei l'aci un segno adesso mi
spacco la tua bronzo dai come un arca
cosa vuol dire bene anche se io non l'ho
mossa io guarda che non è che viene dall
archivio se metto il video non dico a
voi giornalisti che da dio non ho fatto
non ho fatto assolutamente perché così
no non lo fosse io seriamente almeno
posso perché avrei voluto far tipo così
questo tassati di teste di cazzo spedito
anche se in questo caso se ci sei batti
un segno chiaramente i tratti punta le
canzoni note di grandissima anno
particolato sistematico l'artista sta
andando z9 incredibile trono psi scena
come che non torna più dentro o ritorno
dentro
rarità maleducazione continuare allora
io non so perché è partito quel [ __ ]
antifurto non lo so però è curioso
quanto è stato preciso santi furto
proprio come ho finito la frase è stata
pazze c'è veramente assurdo non credo
che sia stato il demone della casa di
milano del web ea quei demoni di milano
che se ne escono tutti dicendo web pari
a zero e kat
poi durante la notte io che sono una
persona stronza ho messo degli effetti
sonori e horror così i miei amici si
sono ragazzi addosso però quello non ho
potuto registrarlo ma meritava la vita
anche quello comunque sia dovete
smetterla di chiedermi della tav
basta in realtà l'ho fatto per levarmelo
dal caso perché la gente continuava a
chiedermi video dopo video e non ci
stavo più dentro e quindi ragazzo li
questo è tutto per il blog di oggi spero
che il mio riflettore appoggiato
nell'angolo non vi abbia da ora che fa
anche da sfondo sta roba
spero che sia erika riflettore non vi
abbiano dato fastidio nec un mi piace
erri il tasto mi piace che sta sotto
proprio sotto harrypotter lo dovete
cliccare ma col gomito prima di
concludere parto con affari domanda da
fare domanda di oggi è secondo voi a
parte infilar mela nel deretano come
posso utilizzarlo a questa merda qui
fatemelo sapere nei commenti e io cerco
di trovargli un occupazione magari nel
prossimo blog vi faccio vedere l'auto è
rimasta in piedi ce vò e [ __ ] però
che vi sia piaciuto ragazzi cose vissuto
sull'argomento è un mi piace anche la
pagina di facebook e come tale
descrizione per eserciti si vede temi
civili diavolo prossimo video dei
ragazzi